you look amazing you look so amazing
congratulations on your honor what do
you make of this Billy eyelash a viral
moment that you guys created on The Late
Late Show Alicia I just feel like there
was such a genuine love between us it
came across and I think people adore her
so much and she's really just allowed
showing people how it looks to be
comfortable being yourself and I admire
her for that and we were able to just
connect and bond and it just feels like
a blessing what did it mean to you
listen she's not the first young woman
who learns her artistry to an Alicia
Keys song on the piano but how cool to
see her a little Billie playing your
song and the thing was is that it was a
real real real surprise like it wasn't
like the fake surprise I was pretending
to be real it was the real surprise and
I was just bugging it again it's just
such a beautiful affirmation for me for
her for our connection and for just all
young artists for people that are
creating that you know you you go do
your thing and look what comes back to
you so I can't even explain it was real
real special okay last thing I know that
you've done this duet now on The Late
Late Show
now Grammys are just a few weeks away
and she's a big nominee are there any
way we can get an Alesha Billie 2.0 on
the Grammys I feel like Billy's gonna
have her own moment that's gonna crush
the building okay that's what I feel
like but watch what comes
[Music]